for pregnancy
men or women or does it take two to
tango so I want to go around everyone
give your take on that question I feel
like it takes two times
okay yeah
um what who's to blame men or women yeah
and this might be a um
what do they call it a
controversial yeah
I say women women why because men don't
know that men are probably just there
for the both obviously both they're like
she's hot in there
they just know so yeah and it is more so
you know if you do get pregnant
who who who's more responsible who's
more responsible for it who's the one
that can have that final decision to the
women
okay
women for sure okay yeah
because I think sex is not itself
um it's more costly to women than men
I think
men have a part to play in it as well
because you know you know what you're
about to do not to believe her
um and I think you need to take
responsibility for the actions
whether if I if the person if the guy
wanted it or not
um
yeah she would be to blame if you want
to say that
yeah 50 50. both to blame
so why do women call themselves the
creators of life when the pregnancy is
wanted oh and the example they use it
anyway I don't think they should use
that term he got me knocked up you got
yourself knocked up like you literally
went into it knew that no matter what
contraception you're taking it's never
do everything right and she can still
steal the condom very wealthy man that's
actually very common for like people in
certain positions most men you're right
it's rare it's not for all men but like
super wealthy men that's very common
they were misled to think she wasn't
taking the pill or something similar I
thought the thing expires in like 10
times yeah I just know every year but to
really learn like most of us I feel like
it's it takes two to tango to get
pregnant and it's I don't know why it's
more women's fault yeah like you said uh
sorry
right
um
it's both to me we all know people who
like there's something there's been some
guys that are quite great girl pregnant
and he wants the baby she doesn't want
it she makes the last decision who's
blame to their pregnant what I'm saying
is I'm just trying to get women pregnant
if you strap up who has the final say
without that pregnancy
we're not saying who has the final seat
to give the beef so beef yeah it's a
woman but you're pregnant it's too too
big yeah but she can change that
situation but wouldn't you say the woman
has more power in general yeah because
because the woman has 41 forms of birth
control you can require the men that
they wear condoms so like what I'm
saying is it's more on the woman because
we have more power I would say yeah it's
it's I would blame the woman because you
know you know when you're ovulating
that was a good point and he does it and
so that's just so much more power that
we have where he could wear a condom and
it breaks just think men are
responsibility so right okay quick
question then if if a girl got pregnant
off a one night both well he's supposed
to have called her to say yo is it your
time
no but both have to blame because both
had sex
or it's a bit of a girl's fault too
he will be half old because she doesn't
um self give a give a [__] about I want
to blame them not even 10 blame me it's
your fault no it's both people no
once once the semen leaves a guy he has
no control do you know what I mean so he
has no control yeah yeah it's different
from fault like yeah once it leaves you
you'll have no control
we pick who has sex yeah
like you're telling me you should say oh
no that's like like I mean I just feel
like men are programmed to do that I
would say women should take more
precaution because it will change their
life way more if you're having a child
but yeah I can I can understand
it's like ten versus one exactly
yeah if I'm if I play for the NFL or
something then I I know it'll probably
hurt me let me ask you be careful it's a
man if you had a son and he got natural
to him so how much would you blame him
like
or for having sex forgetting someone
pregnant and being what do you mean okay
he could have had condenser and he broke
advised to be shooting up in random
chicks yeah like that's not wise but the
point is we have so much more power than
the men that like if I had to blame
someone I'm blaming the woman I don't
think it's 50 50. even I don't even
think it's close to 50 50. we can
require they wear condoms or not and
it's like we have all of these
precautions where the men have won I
feel like we just start looking who to
blame who to blame because then I could
say oh my parents never told me anything
I didn't know much it's just my nature
and I done it um yeah but there's Google
like come on no I would say I didn't
know many things on my phone no one knew
so
you know they don't talk nowadays they
very push this free movement right and
no one said oh save yourself like my
parents I had no talk about
relationships so
I forgot what you have sex same with the
guy if if he has unprotected he can't
say oh some girl got pregnant I feel
like it's 50 you got some girl pregnant
but I'm gonna tell him that he's
irresponsible obviously no I was
irresponsible for obviously shooting up
the club but what yes that's true I
agree you know why do you think there
hasn't been male birth control
it's not medically like impossible or do
you think if they wanted to find it they
could have I I have a hard time
believing that they're creating
artificial wounds but they couldn't feel
I asked you guys the question
I could tell you my opinion after but
why don't you guys I'm assuming it might
be harder to
but I'm sure I saw right sorry sorry I'm
just saying assuming it might be harder
as
it's a lot of a lot of sperm swimming
around in there stop all our soldiers
running in yeah it might be a bit more
tricky it could be also that I don't
know
um if you were to give main
contraceptions would just be you know um
what do you think what do you think
Society how do you think society would
change if we gave it would take over
they would have all the power then
I agree
I feel like
yeah
that you probably see less of you know
um on plant babies because we're more
logical I think so no I haven't had um
surround because men will actually be a
lot more responsible because they know
yeah the effects of their either their
promiscuity or I mean so there would be
um a lot more careful
about probably who they sleep with or
they'll make sure they actually take the
contraceptives or whatever it is like a
reverse role yeah how it is now yeah
so I think there'll be less single
parents around yeah I agree and probably
less children because a lot of men
probably don't want to have children
until later on in life so there'd be
less children and
the society will be probably like Japan
where there are one child
what did you when you said that men are
irresponsible what did you mean by it
like if it depends which where you are
um and but I think
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on
a platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible